these teenagers are some of the 5 000
members of a youth movement in the
pro-russia separatist controlled region
of eastern ukraine
they are all still at school
unami roughly translates to army of the
youth
instructors many of them former
separatist fighters say they teach
patriotism and how to defend the
self-declared republic of donetsk
which after eight years of conflict with
ukraine remains unrecognized by any
country in the world even its main
backer russia
the students are taught a range of
skills including martial arts first aid
and assembling and disassembling weapons
which we are not allowed to film
fourteen-year-old christina joined two
years ago after her cousin was killed
during fighting between the
russian-backed separatists and the
ukrainian army
it's very painful for me when i remember
he was like my brother
i joined because of his death because i
wanted to remember those lost in the war
especially
we don't want to make the same mistakes
that we did when the soviet union was
attacked in world war ii
murals in the school corridors celebrate
russian history and cultural figures
like the novelist and poet alexander
pushkin
a map shows crimea painted in the
colours of the russian flag
today's class is about the victory of
soviet forces over the nazis in the
battle of stalingrad considered one of
the bloodiest battles in history
claiming around 2 million lives
feels like my second family my second
home when you go through so much
together you become very close
it develops our patriotism we remember
and are proud of our predecessors i want
to eventually serve in the army
outside the students prepare for a mock
battle
they split into two opposing sides and
fire at each other using laser guns and
stacks of tyres as cover
but this
isn't just a game
this might look like fun but of course
it has serious implications and it's
important to recognize that there are
similar youth groups on the ukrainian
government control side also being
trained like this there they are taught
that the danger is what the ukrainians
describe as a russian expansionism with
its roots in the soviet past
here instructors tell the children that
the danger is an ideology that has huge
resonance with both the young and the
older
ukraine is not our enemy fascism is the
enemy in 2014 when the conflict started
we were standing up against fascists
like our grandparents did we can't say
we have enemies our only enemy is
fascism we don't want to adjust to make
fascism our friend
christina and her friends are too young
to fully understand how history can be
manipulated to serve military or
political ends in any conflict
a few kilometers away are the abandoned
ruins of homes and places where children
once played destroyed in eight years of
war with no peaceful solution in sight a
conflict into which the young on both
sides are being drawn
charles stratford al-jazeera donetsk